[Music]
welcome to the rise and fall of
globalization debate
um and we're going to talk about an
issue that is really perhaps more urgent
than
than it was even six months ago so
we've traded goods across the continents
for centuries in some cases for
thousands of years but it wasn't until
the 20th century that globalization
really
came of age with most primary goods
being sourced internationally
and now there's a growing challenge to
this phenomenon from across the
political spectrum
and localism is a word favored by
brexiteers by the left even by greens
so do we need urgently to pursue
localism
as a response to inequality to access
and to a crisis of resources that
globalization has produced
or is globalization a positive force so
um globalization is in all kinds of
trouble
is localism uh the future um
where should we begin vince is local is
in the future
uh yes i i don't see this antithesis
between localism and globalism as you
pose the question i mean i'm all in
favor of more
local decision making uh stronger local
government
i'm all in favor of global integration
because of the very great benefits it's
brought since the second world war
we've had more trade investment people
flow
technology diffusing
and it's brought in its work a massive
multiplication of living standards of
course it's brought
problems externalities environmental and
others but in overall great benefits
particularly lifting hundreds of
millions of people out of poverty
out of absolute poverty millennium goals
being reached of course we've had
big problems with the financial crisis
and latterly with
the pandemic but i think these are
transitional problems
and we will return hopefully uh
if the nationalist politicians like
trump
don't throw a big spanner in the works
uh to
the the kind of uh integration that we
were used to hopefully with stronger
systems of governance as i say you know
we've had brexit we've had trump uh
these are major
interruptions with what is essentially a
beneficial process
mark you you supported um britain
leaving
one of the world's largest free trade
areas does that mean that you're a fan
of localism you see that as the future
uh no not at all i mean i broadly agree
with
vince i think he and i would probably
share the view that
in the uk in particular uh political
power is ludicrously
centralized uh the the number of
decisions
about expenditure and policy that are
made uh at a white hall level
as opposed at a local level by councils
or devolved assemblies by mayors
is is ludicrous it's it's in excess
really of 90 percent of power
resides in westminster if you were to
aggregate who's actually making spending
decisions
so to that extent i'm i believe in
devolution
but i take the threat to globalization
and i agree with vince that there is a
threat
uh that uh to come not from empowering
political decisions to be made at local
level but the
the coming suggestion that we should
strive enormously more for
self-sufficiency
you mentioned isabel at the outset that
this term localism is
used by lots of different people but it
seems to be used to mean lots of
different things
uh it's very different to say that a
local community should have greater
powers
over let's say its own transport
infrastructure or
setting uh the curriculum in its own
schools to suggesting that a local
community should seek to
make its own wine build its own iphones
construct its own cars
and be blocked off from the rest of the
world in terms of the benefits of trade
and to
underscore what vince was saying the uh
the advances made by globalization
by which i simply mean the number of
transactions
crossing borders going up is heroic i
mean it
it is absolutely monumental from 080
to 1800 average global incomes rose from
about
800 us dollars in today's money a person
to about eleven 1100
so from the 1800 years between the birth
of jesus christ and the election
as thomas jefferson to the u.s
presidency average global incomes rose
by about 40 percent
progress of assault i guess but since
1800 when globalization begins although
i agree isabel is
being more emphatically a 20th century
issue
incomes have risen by 1 200
uh and it's been staggering the last
time
some people more yeah sure but i mean
this is a colossal
advance in human prosperity and wealth
and vince mentioned poverty extreme
poverty has fallen
from 94 of the human race in 1820
living in extreme poverty to around
eight or nine percent
today eight or nine percent too high i i
grant you you want that number to be
naught percent
but wow we seem to have found the
medicine
to tackle this problem uh similarly life
expectancy has risen
since 1820 by uh average life expectancy
was 35 years now globally at 71 years
you'll be right the people living in
rich western countries it's higher still
than that
but the scale of progress has been i
mean absolutely remarkable probably
the most spectacular human experiment
definitely the most spectacular human
experiment in our history with
unbelievably spectacular results if
human welfare prosperity and flourishing
are what you're
aiming for so uh whilst i would like to
see political
decentralization and that does raise
issues about how you go about that in
order to ensure there are not
uh trade barriers but i would like more
decisions about local things taken at
local level
i am worried that we are beginning to
unravel
this superb network of international
globalized free trade
that has brought with it unbelievably
spectacular gains
uh which we would not want to see going
to reverse at all great thank you
thank you very much grace um some
some discussion about what localism is
but but i'm guessing
you have a rather clear idea of what it
is and and do you see it as the future
well yeah i mean to me localism means
local democratic accountability
and i think that is something that has
perhaps been lost over the last
phase of globalization that we've been
through and i think when discussing
globalization
it's very important to identify a series
of distinct phases now of course
globalization as we understand it today
is really a phenomenon that's it's
interwoven
inexorably really with the process of
the development of capitalism
so you know we have uh several initial
rounds of globalization starting yes
arguably around 1800
uh the each of which are kind of
punctuated by various forms of crises so
obviously towards the end of the 1900s
the beginning of the 20th century
you have this lasse fair mode of
globalization um associated with you
know extremely high levels of
growing inequalities and also
underpinned by a very extractive form of
colonialism that ends with the great
depression
i then have a kind of you know 15-year
period of crisis
uh which is followed by the creation of
the bretton woods institutions after the
second world war
and that leads to this uh phase of
globalization that lasts from about 1945
to uh to around the mid-70s uh which is
underpinned by those bretton woods
institutions for the creation of the imf
the world bank
um the uh gap which then became the wto
um
and uh associated with that was a regime
of exchange rate
so the various major currencies around
the world were pegged to one another
and what was sorry were pegged to the
dollar and the dollar was then pegged to
gold so this was underpinned by a
particular form
of uh exchange rate management uh
effectively
it was also associated with various
other mechanisms to kind of hem in
a very particular form of globalization
which was financial globalization so
uh capital controls were quite common
during this era
this then ended during the 1970s uh when
the us decides to come off gold famously
um at least partly to the emergence of
this big
foreign account deficit partly due to
the war in vietnam various other reasons
and after that bretton woods is steadily
unwound and you start to see the
emergence of free-floating exchange
rates
capital account liberalization and we
enter a period of financial
globalization which comes around from
about the 1980s
and obviously the crisis of that model
is the financial crisis of 2008.
now financial globalization is
associated with a huge increase
in capital mobility in particular not
necessarily trade although trade does
continue to grow
predominantly uh investment and capital
flows between countries
and associated with this we see the
emergence of these big imbalances
between
different countries and so some
countries gain big
have big current account deficits
associated with lots of flows into their
assets
um and other countries have big current
account surpluses uh so they're kind of
uh
investing in other parts of the world
and what was really interesting about
this period aside from
uh you know the all the things that we
could say about the the growth of this
kind of very over leveraged
international banking system
i think one of the most interesting
things about this period is yes poverty
decreases so quite substantially
predominantly due to the
growth of china it becomes a
middle-income country along with various
other middle income countries
those countries which sought to actually
defy the rules imposed by international
financial institutions operating
based on the washington consensus saying
we have to impose
capital mobility often done through
structural adjustment programs and
various other kind of neo-colonial
methods basically to
enforce the openness to international
trade and international capital flows
those countries that that did the best
during this period were the ones that
were actually
relatively closed off to international
capital flows i'm thinking particularly
here
of china whereas those uh particularly
sub-saharan african nations
which we're told if you just open up
your country to capital flows to across
the world
you will eventually catch up that has
been shown to be a big lie they remain
really uh dependent upon commodities
they remain
overloaded by debt they're subject to
massive capital outflows particularly
due to tax avoidance and those flows
often go through this network of secrecy
jurisdictions
um around the world associated with the
city of london so
this most recent round of financial
globalization which ended in the crisis
of 2008 and
since which we've seen a kind of period
of deglobalization
has created a whole host of problems and
i think the
reinsertion of local democracy local
accountability
and actually national democracy and
national sovereignty over one's policies
uh is a really important corrective to
that
great thank you very much um mark i'm
going to come back to you you painted
the very
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas